when you watch or listen to the news
have you noticed that there are a few
topics that always get covered
weather sports unfortunately politics
and news about the stock market while it
may be easy to understand the weather or
sports segments
stock market news can feel like a secret
code you know some people make a lot of
money
somehow but how if the stock market
confuses you
you're not alone according to the global
2014 survey
two-thirds of adults are not financially
literate it's not your fault schools
don't teach this stuff
but the good news is you can understand
the basics quite easily
first what even is stock
imagine taking a company and breaking it
into a lot of tiny pieces
a stock is one of those small pieces or
a share of a company and when we say a
lot of tiny pieces
we mean a lot amazon for instance is
made up of over 500 million shares
when you buy a stock you're buying one
or more of those pieces of a company
for the most part you can only buy
shares of public companies
a public company is one whose shares are
available on a public market
called a stock market while many large
national companies
are public not all of them are in fact
of the approximately 600 000 u.s
companies
with at least 20 employees less than one
percent
are public for example say you really
like candy and want to live out your
willy wonka fantasies
by owning a piece of a candy company if
you want to buy shares of mars the
company behind
m m's snickers and skittles too bad it's
a private company
so you can't buy any shares of it
instead you might have to settle for
hershey's which
is a public company and so offers its
shares in the stock market
now that we know what a stock is let's
go back to the news when you hear
the stock market went up that means that
overall the price for pieces of public
companies increase
this doesn't mean every company share
went up just that across
the whole stock market people generally
paid more for pieces for a company today
than they did yesterday but when you
hear the opposite
the stock market went down that means
that on a whole
the traders paying less for stocks today
than they were yesterday
you may hear things like the dow was up
today or
the s p was down today but what does
that mean the dow and the s
p also known as the s p 500 are bundles
of stock
that are actually considered to be
representative of the stock market as a
whole
think of it as an appetizer sampler
platter with some pieces
a lot of different things the dow is a
collection of 30 different companies
while the s p 500 reflects the shares of
500 different companies
while people often use the dow or the s
p 500
as stand-ins for how the stock market is
doing it is important to realize the
stock market
is not a stand-in for how the economy is
doing this may be counterintuitive since
many of us associate the economy with
the stock market
but they are different things the
economy is a big and complex system
so big so complex that it's actually
hard to even define
encompasses different metrics like the
employment rate the prices of goods and
services
taxes and a myriad of other factors all
interrelated and affecting one another
because the economy as a whole is so big
and complex but the stock market is
relatively easy to understand
the dow goes up dow goes down many
people use a stock market
as a substitute in their minds for the
economy as a whole
think of the entire economy like a
football stadium the stock market is
like the scoreboard
it tells you a lot of useful information
about what's going on inside the
football stadium
the score players stats the number of
people in attendance
but you never say the entire football
stadium is the scoreboard
it may be important part of it but
there's so much more to the economy
than the stock market in fact there are
times when the stock market and the
economy can become disconnected for
instance during
the 2020 coronavirus pandemic the stock
market is reaching new highs
millions of americans however are
expecting financial disaster
how can that be the answer is in the
fact that a booming stock market
only directly benefits those who own
stock according to the new york times 84
of stock owned by americans belong to
the wealthiest 10 percent of households
that means when the stock market's doing
well those at the top
benefit the most according to one of the
most influential economists of the 20th
century
milton freeman a ceo is an employee of
the owners of the company
i.e the shareholders this means her only
responsibility is to maximize profit
since profit is revenue minus cost her
job is literally to keep costs
down a major cost for many companies is
salaries and benefits for its workers if
a company were to announce
raises for all their employees it would
certainly benefit the finances of those
employees
however it would make the cost of doing
business to go up so according to
friedman in order to do her job and
increase stock prices
a ceo would look to keep employees
compensation down
so even if you work for a company whose
stock prices is going up
it doesn't necessarily mean your
economic fortunes are improving
so how do average people like us get
stocks and how do you make sure you make
money and don't lose money there's no
shortage of companies or apps that will
allow you to buy or sell stocks
together called trading do some research
before picking one
as many may have fees that outweigh any
money you expect to gain by
trading once you set up a stock trading
account called a brokerage account a
trading a stock is actually pretty easy
a simple stock trade can be broken down
into three steps
buy one or more shares at the price the
market is selling them
two wait some amount of time it could be
minutes
days months years or even decades
during this time the price of the stock
will change for all kinds of reasons
that people spend their entire lives
trying to understand
three sell those shares at the price the
market is buying them
that's it there are more complicated
ways of investing into the stock market
but this process is a basic one buy
something
wait until the price change and then
sell it you want the price to go up
after you buy something
but it might go down to make money
hopefully you can follow the
conventional wisdom of
buy low sell high you might be wondering
how do i know if the value of a stock is
going up or down
unfortunately you don't that's sort of
the whole point of the stock market when
you buy a stock you're essentially
making a bet that over time
the stock will become more valuable than
it was when you bought it
prices however can go down meaning you
might find yourself selling your shares
for less than you paid for them
that's how you lose money since no one
knows a future in general it's pretty
foolish to think that you can time the
stock market whenever you hear someone
with flashy stock market tips or
no lose trading strategies they're
almost certainly lying
and trying to sell you something no one
knows how to make guaranteed money in
the stock market if they did
they would keep the secret to themselves
and spend all their time making money
that way
it's similar to when you see scam
exercise products advertised
that promise easy results it's just for
suckers
the tried and true way to make money in
the stock market is slow
boring investing so you have money when
you're older buy some stocks and don't
sell them again for ages
even if the market goes down even if the
market soars
a good way to do this is with retirement
products such as iras and 401ks
over the long run the stock market has
trended upwards
which is why a steady unexciting
investment plan is usually the best
one again like exercising products if
you want to get healthier
the tried and true way is consistent
diet and exercise
not the quick gimmicks to wrap things up
while the basics of the stock market are
easy to understand
buy wait sell before you do any
investing it's important to do much more
research than this video provided
talk to qualified financial planners
people who you trust to be looking out
for your financial well-being
and not trying to make a quick buck
there's no rush
the stock market isn't going anywhere
and neither are the news segments
reporting on it
hopefully however now you understand a
bit more of what those stories mean
[Music]
you